- Couple things.
You can't oversell
yourself on this decision
at 20 years that I'm not
capable of building a business,
or I'm just a creator and
a salesman is ludicrous.
It just is.
(mellow hip hop music)
(clicking)
Hey, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Good, what's cooking?
- Just wanted to catch up.
Been a while.
- Yeah.
How's it going?
(mumbling)
Mine's a disaster.
You forget the cadence of the door
when you're not here every day.
Push not pull
How's it going?
You know, you started in a very weird way.
You know, one of the
advantages I probably--
- Too much success and I get,
not success in that way, but...
- I totally, no you're exactly,
you're going right down
the exact right path,
which is, go in the front, Iris,
which is, yo, what's up man?
Right I forgot you're here.
(laughing)
Get in here, get in here.
We're good.
- [Jordan] We got another one here.
- [Iris] Hey, Jordan.
- [Jordan] Hey, how are you?
- I'm gonna try wield power both of them.
When you're coming from that
high of plan and expectations,
you may not be enjoying
it because of that.
- I'm putting my pressure, it's insane.
I put so much pressure on myself.
- Way too much.
I believe that.
You'd rather create and sell.
You need to create the
bucket that helps operate it.
I had the luxury of years
and years of doing it.
- Where?
Wine Library?
- Yeah.
That's what I had to learn, right?
It was cool to sell a hundred cases,
like this is year, what?
This is 1996.
We just sold a hundred
cases on the internet.
How do you ship it?
- Yeah.
- It was all logistics, right?
I got into that.
You did what you did,
you had that success.
You come over, you start hanging with me.
You start meeting all these people.
(mumbling)
And more importantly,
but here's what happened,
you start spending time with me,
If I'm you, and I'm having me tell you
that you're gonna be
great and unstoppable,
and you're meeting some
people like, wow, wow, wow.
You start creating this
huge amount of pressure.
This is why prospects fail.
This is why number one picks--
- I feel like what's his name, Grant Hill.
(laughing)
I feel like a huge Grant Hill.
- Well you didn't get hurt.
- I feel like an injured Grant Hill.
- This is what you're doing,
but you're doing it to yourself.
It's not like that many people--
- It's all up here.
- I'm aware, that's
why I'm talking to you.
You're putting the pressure
of all the narrative
that was built in a
year that we all jammed,
you just need to take a
little bit of a breath.
Couple things, you can't oversell yourself
on this decision at 20
years that I'm not capable
of building a business or I'm
just a creator and a salesman
is ludicrous, it just is.
You know, it's you wanting,
you trying to formulate
what is social media accounts
into a media company.
- Yeah.
- You know, like, people,
listen, you know one of the
things that really happened
early on that I really loved about you?
Is when I spoke to you early on--
- You said, I don't
wanna be here for a year.
- No.
(laughing)
when I spoke to you and I was like hey
there's a big difference
between me and these hucksters,
like those voices that
were getting in your head,
I could see you being thoughtful,
and not dismissing it as bullshit.
That's kind of what I
feel about now, right?
There's a fundamental difference between
building a media company,
and having accounts
on top of social media
networks on an arbitrage.
That's it.
- Yes.
- And that shit matters.
And the ultimate is to do what I do.
- Both.
- Right.
But I'm also 42 and a
lot of million things
have happened, so to
me, I genuinely believe
you can do both.
Maybe not want to.
I definitely don't want you
to do anything except for you.
- Yeah.
- I just want you to
not go, you know listen,
I always believe the person,
actually I think Jordan and I,
it's so funny that he's here,
yesterday we were working
out and Jordan said to me
the favorite thing you've ever said,
or the biggest thing I took
away from you was what, Jordan?
- About being the bigger person.
- [Gary] Yeah, but what was it?
Emotion, what was the quote?
- The best part is that
letting your emotions
dictate your actions is the
greatest sign of weakness.
- And that's what's
happening right now with you.
I wanna take that
variable out a little bit,
and take it from the tilt
that it's on right now,
to at least, take it from 110 to 80.
It still may be right.
But we have to have this conversation
under 80 energy, not 110.
I wanna help you.
It makes me happy to help you.
I care about you.
- I like that.
I appreciate that.
- Let me tell you the most important thing
you need to hear from me.
You can literally decide
tomorrow to be 20,
let all of this go to zero, and win big.
I genuinely believe that.
- I think so too.
- Good.
So, honestly, if that's what you believe,
and I know you believe that,
that means to put you
in a very good place,
because then you're
playing with house money.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I just, the talent and the
learning is already put,
and the youth, has put
you in an incredible spot.
The other thing I'd recommend,
please consider when you're in New York
to come and jam out in the office.
Just come and hang.
- I'd love to come and hang.
- Good to see you.
Alright, Jordan, thank you.
Jordan, my plan here is,
about filming things here.
My intuition is if I
finish this right now,
the only thing I'll
need is a Caesar salad.
That's my plan.
- [Jordan] Let's do it.
You feel good?
Not so much.
- I feel good today.
I've not accomplished anything.
- [Jordan] You ate a lot yesterday?
- Less than I did the day before,
but I didn't weigh myself.
I'm just not, just nowhere to be had.
Like, I mentioned it three, four days ago.
I need to get you out of love
and get me focused and like,
I have to figure this out.
I'm just not in the game.
- [Jordan] The girl that--
- I'm making a joke, I'm making a joke.
I need you to shadow me.
Can you do me a favor?
This would matter.
Can you call Mike or see him
and ask him his perspective
on his hovering,
like what worked best?
Because I'm gonna need to reset it.
I'm just not there.
I feel amazing about today,
only because I saw the
number today I'm like,
great, accomplish nothing.
So I'm on tilt the other way.
Because of this.
If I didn't ask for this,
I would have fucking
ate everything in there.
- [Jordan] Yeah, that's good.
- So I know this is my biggest win
when I'm in New York.
- [Jordan] Yeah, we're
gonna have to figure out LA,
'cause we're there all week.
- We just have to take it seriously.
We.
I can't do it myself.
- [Jordan] Got it.
- If I could do it myself,
I wouldn't hire you guys.
We're just not in the we game.
So we just have to hack.
We have to have the conversation
I just had with Dunk.
At least I'm (mumbling).
Feeling grown, I feel
motivated, I feel incredible.
But a lot of great.
I'm not gonna lose weight.
Just not in it.
Only way you can win is you
face your demon probably.
I'm not, I don't think, in the two weeks,
I've had two days that
were up to the standard of
what I would do.
Just nowhere in the game.
I should have had you stay
in the house in the basement.
I'm doing the things that are wrong.
What should have happened?
Like if you're in it, if you're
truly gonna lose 10 pounds,
you need to be in the Hamptons every day,
you need to be in the basement,
and you need to come
up and fucking feed me.
That's what I signed up for.
We'd got into such a place
where we didn't have to,
because it worked, and so why put stress
on either one of us if it's working.
But I'm not winning the nutrition game.
- [Jordan] No, it's not there, yeah.
- Nope.
- [Jordan] Okay.
- You know, the whole like shadow me,
being around me thing,
we've never had to do it.
You kinda came and never did it.
The way I was intending on doing it.
Because I was coming off serious fasting,
and I was going right
into muscle building,
so I was allowed to eat, so I was like,
why do I need him to
sit here or bother him.
And it didn't bother me,
but I think we have to go to babysitting.
- [Jordan] Alright, yeah.
- So we'll have to take it,
at least, I don't need you
to babysit me for the next
16 months, but in my
quest to lose some weight,
which I'd like to because I'm,
my bigger probably is if
I was at 167, I'd be okay,
because I'd be at a weight
that's acceptable to me.
But all that's happened
is my weight's going up.
And I'm not in a good rhythm.
And I kind of started talking
about it couple months ago,
I always thought it'd
be easy, it's just not.
I'm a year and fucking, how
long have we been together now?
- [Jordan] Almost two years in May.
- Two years.
I'm a year and a half
into not eating that way.
- [Jordan] Yeah, it's not habit right now.
- And literally outside
of getting sick in Ghana,
which kinda like saved me
during that bad period,
I haven't shown anything that makes me
respect the way I'm going about this.
- [Jordan] Got it, understood.
- And I feel it.
You can, right?
- [Jordan] No, no, you can tell.
- I can tell in my content,
Iris, I'm fatter than I used to be, right?
You can feel it.
- [Iris] Um.
- Tell the truth, Iris.
- [Iris] Not overweight,
compared to maybe two years ago.
- [Jordan] I see it in your jawline.
- Right, I see it in my jawline too.
- [Jordan] I do, I'm serious.
- They see it.
- [Iris] I've seen videos
from a couple years ago that
(mumbling) but you still look (mumbling).
- I couldn't agree more.
I've lost.
Now I've gotta win.
- [Jordan] I got it back.
And I need you to, you need
to go into a different gear.
You're just not gonna have flexibility,
you're just gonna have to shadow me.
- [Jordan] Cool.
- At least when it matters.
And use Tyler and Avi,
and like we're just gonna have to hack.
- [Jordan] Yeah, that's good.
I'll see you in LA.
- Have a chat with Mike, Jordan.
Just because he might have
an insight that I don't know.
But most of all have a
quick talk with yourself.
- [Jordan] Got it.
- Because it's life changing for you.
At least for (mumbling)
It's tough, you have so much, I, you know,
right now we're acting
like a normal client
that people have 30 of.
That's what we're doing.
We're working out, we're leaving.
(laughing)
I just (mumbling).
I need you.
- [Jordan] Got it.
- Cool.
(mellow music)